have you ever heard of mort's cornelis  uh sure that's MC escher if you're  feeling old he's the man who proved that  gravity is for chumps and I bet he had  no idea that he would influence video  games 40 years after his death Monument  Valley dazzles and enthralls the  elaborate structure springing to life is  you proud the contraptions with your  finger and you know what I'm glad this  has touchscreen controls I feel like a  giant God transforming the world to my  whims plus my mute Valley is mighty  fine-looking quiet and serene the hour i  spent solving spatial puzzles and  raptured me and i'm not one who normally  plays on mobile but i can't deny  something special when it lands on my  lap intrigued drop four dollars on this  piece of digital art for whatever iOS  device you have and praise the  imagination of the long dead Dutchman  with the catchy name